le chez nero concours vont bientôt
former une seule et même commune les
deux conseils municipaux ont voté ce
lundi 18 juin le principe de faisabilité
d'une fusion cette nouvelle ville
regroupera sous le nom le chez nero
concours trente deux mille habitants
début janvier 2019 avec un seul maire à
sa tête
nous nous avons travaillé depuis le mois
de septembre régulièrement pour
apprécier le bien fondé de cette
nouvelle commune
et quand nous avons fait nos deux
colonnes le pour et le contre et bien
avons vu qu'au mois de mars le colonnes
pour était quasiment rempli dans la
colonne des pour selon les élus cette
mesure permettra au concours de
bénéficier des structures et des
services de la ville du chesnay dans le
sens inverse les chaînés zir pourraient
eux réaliser des économies en réduisant
notamment les indemnités sur le manque
de logements sociaux c'est
l'optimisation des dépenses qui est
importante même s'il y a effectivement
dotation globale de fonctionnement qui
est bonifié et même si effectivement sur
l'arrêté de carence il y aura plutôt des
bons résultats et nous aurons aussi
également de bonnes actions d'urbanisme
dans ce sens aux chaînés la fusion
recueilli 30 et une voix pour et 2
contre l'opposition a critiqué le manque
de communication conseil municipal il y
aurait préféré une autre orientation
stratégique pour la ville nous
considérons que la cette fusion arrive
bien tardivement
parce que la vie leur concours est
beaucoup trop petit désormais pour pour
fusionner avec le chesnay dans les
circonstances actuelles il faut
fusionner plus tôt avec une grande ville
en l'occurrence versailles pour arriver
une taille critique puissante pour peser
dans le grand paris prochaine étape la
présentation globale du projet le 8
octobre prochain le futur nom des
habitants n'est lui pas encore connue
pourrait être soumis à une consultation
sur internet